all right check the gate guys i'll go on
three three two one action
[Music]
foundation is the greatest science
fiction work of all time it's a story of
ideas and they are bold ideas
the visual effects are really cutting
edge we're going to see things that we
haven't ever seen the series before
it was a huge collaborative effort it
was a thousand people working on the
show to get it finished just from a
visual effects perspective
we had so many different minds working
on this project it was a real global
effort to get it designed and built and
shot for sure
these days it's mostly digitally done
but in the case of foundation we're
actually going to build miniature models
of some of the spacecraft and some of
the locations and then integrate them
into the visual effects
we start with concept art turning it
into a digital model
we can then translate that digital model
into a file that we can use to 3d print
so we're taking the digital asset and
turning it into a physical asset
we're shooting things physically like
blowing things up in cloud tanks or
shooting our miniatures against an led
screen
photographing it with motion control
cameras
we're taking different methods of doing
visuals trying to get every physical
aspect we can
[Music]
whenever we approach science fiction we
always wanted to feel grounded like
exploring the look and style of the
costumes we're looking at like desert
societies and inuit societies
you have these different characters
coming from different worlds it's easier
to look at those characters and think
where are they coming from my gal came
from synax which is a water plant
each world we took what their
environment was for design choices to
help make our foundation universe look
completely original
you have characters coming from all
sorts of different worlds different
classes they'll dress different and
they'll sound differently
most languages have different patterns
something that would make them unique
stand out
people from an acquaintance these are
warrior-like so if they're blunt they're
hard-hitting they just come out with it
the other language has this they're a
bit more laid-back so that gives certain
qualities to the language it sets them
apart
with foundation we are trying to do for
science fiction with game of thrones
different fantasy
which is present a fully realized world
with a level of sophistication that's
never been seen on television before
seeing the work that everyone has put in
and how much love has gone into it and
it's going to be one heck of a show
you